on ne fait des scénarios où on a imaginé
que les immigrants par exemple qui
arrive en europe avaient le même niveau
d'éducation que ceux qui arrivent au
canada parce qu'elles sont importants
puis le canada c'est l'excellent mieux
c'est immigrantes la 3d pays grâce à sa
politique d'immigration fait s'améliorer
en parlera pas de 40 ans on ne fait
aussi des scénarios où on ne se pose et
le niveau d'activité de tous les
européennes est si évident atteignez le
niveau des suédois donc ça existe les
suédois ont les taux d'activité un taux
de chômage il y avait 21 pour le
économique
y'a pas de raison que ça puisse pas être
possible a par ailleurs mailly fo il
faut avoir une politique que
l'économique et c'est pour y arriver
mais ça existe donc si on suppose que
tout les européens travaillent aussi
intensément que les suédois ils
produisent la même manière que leur
niveau d'éducation samilia comme on peut
le prévoir
et c'est en fait malgré le
vieillissement démographique la
situation de la fiscalité ou de la
conductivité du rendement de la
population équipe par rapport à celle
qui est inactive pourrait s'améliorer ce
qui est un message essama positive par
rapport à tous les messages qu'on hausse
depuis longtemps sur les problèmes que
peuvent causer de vis dans des matériaux
qui en fait c'était le message qui
pourrait rassurer certaines personnes
qui craignent que dans l'avenir le poids
des communautés qui sont vieillissantes
peut être lots pour les générations qui
viennent derrière eux
donc ça peut atténuer cette espèce de
sentiment mais il faut s'occuper de
publier personnes mais ça va nous coûter
cher
effectivement effectivement c'est une
message principal de résultats porté par
les résultats de cette étude c'est que
le vieillissement démographique qui dit
inimitable dans le sens plus
à moins qu'on tue tout comme à risque
allié faible la retraite on va avoir un
va pas de dépendance démographique qui
vont de moins en moins favorables par
contre si on tient compte d'autres
facteurs comme la productivité des
jeunes travaillent à la hausse du niveau
d'éducation etc
la situation pourrait être en fait
meilleur qu'aujourd'hui dans un futur
plus visible